this is a production of Cornell
University season is about to start
hopefully in about 20 days Oh would you
yeah yeah so the video the video that's
playing right now is was taken a few
days ago and it's one of our orchard
orchards where we measure lots of things
productivity and and yield efficiency
and so forth I'll be talking about all
those some of those
Burbage later but it's one of the ways
that we're evolving given the title of
my talk things started 50 years ago I'm
51 years old and and so you can imagine
how long it's taken to get here yeah I
was why I was 1 years old I was just
planting those root stocks right there
it's easier to reach the the but at the
graft union when you're on your time
your your little but no I
so it's it it's it's nice to be standing
on the shoulders of really great people
that started the breeding program a long
time ago I'll have a few images pictures
from the 1970s and 1980s I I took a few
hours this past week and and I got into
her bow linkle who is this fellow right
here and this fellow right here who had
a collection of you know the old slides
that use this light projector so I scan
a few lumen and you'll see some of them
but the the breeding program was
essentially the the idea of Jim Cummings
here is last year and we here receiving
a very nice
award from the from a group I think it
was is HS and and then the breeding
program was joined by Terrence Robinson
and of course herb retired the wild
while back and and and so we we've now
made a formal collaboration with dr. a
vice cons but there are lots of
components to bring programs and other
people working on it so I'll be
highlighting some some other people who
have worked on the beef like Charlie who
passed away a few years back and top
dollar and serve our there both of the
technicians that that work in the green
room currently and to a great job so
here's an old picture that I took from
herb slides and here's herb and you know
he's presenting a poster but I think
that's also heard in in England and see
screaming beard of some sort but love it
again a lot of people have contributed
and continue to contribute a lot of
students have participated in the past
few years and in in the breeding program
doing all sorts of things so we have a
bee who is more of a stable technician
she's the propagation specialist in ER
in a program and some went on to become
Cornell students here's David and then
we have some some more that have
actually joined us going sailing this
was one of our sailing parties and we
had students coming from Hobart William
Smith and and Utah State participated in
the scarlet Summer Scholars bra projects
also students from BYU and
here's one of our meetings where we're
discussing the what to do in you know
and in there
reading through all the building
projects and things that we were
undertaking that this past year we have
more students more people who have
worked on the program and I like you
familiar with some of them I think he
was Jim to renew his technician and then
earn his PhD here and so now is dr.
Quinn so he started back in 2002 2003
with us we have Jack and Jana rarely
each and one and my neighbor Ava
increased after I think he's a medical
doctor now and and that is quickly is
was a postdoc or visiting scientist in
Thomas Robinson program that did a lot
of work on roots and in replant
resistors and things like that more
people so there's Phil for sling and
Phil was one of the initial technicians
that work in the breeding program 50
years ago or 40 something years ago and
Phil went on to become retired as a
recent research leader of the usda unit
and how appropriate he in this picture
that i found among my things standing
next to a fire blight stricken tree and
there is fire in the background so what
a nice picture stefan the mazaki from
italy who was a business I insist lab
that's herb Gustafson and then boric
famous husband helping with inoculations
we have Kathy that is you know you'll
see another picture later measuring
things like fruit numbers and new
suckers and whatnot another picture of
herb with your son Dean who is a
Michigan State so a lot of people it
takes it's it's it's amazing how people
has taken to get to this place and I
have to recognize all of them
a few more students now postdocs are
good but students are great because of
really the very nice contribution that
they make to program here is Ali I think
he's present in this room raise your
hand
Ali there we go there's not a picture of
you with menacing with you yet with an
x-ray machine in next few minutes and
other students
that's Nicola Giudice who worked a lot
on evaluating our plant material for
fire by resistance and then to 200
students have worked on and they're the
part of the Adams family and they own a
nursery
one of them is the director now a
propagation of Willow Drive nursery and
the other one is sign varieties so
they're all going to do great things but
in the process they've all study police
dogs okay moving on and of course I have
to recognize all my colleagues and
collaborators that are and these are
this is just a small list of the
us-based collaborators but we have
obviously over a hundred people that
have collaborated with a breeding
program and just in the US and maybe if
we go into other countries we also have
that probably the same number so I
recognize all of them I I realized that
that valuating Apple Rouge stocks are
working with root systems and root
stocks in general is a very difficult
thing to do and and and I appreciate the
work that they've done to collaborate so
a little bit of a review and real quick
what does a root stock do in the orchard
and we've learned a lot in these past
few years about how a root can modify
the architecture of the grafted tsiyon
but
and on top of doing the architecture
you'll see later on that it does a lot
more than that but but and other other
things that it does obviously in
interfaces inside the soil with
microbiota and and soil particles
collects the water and all those all
those good things to make the sign more
productive and it has to be resistant
brew stock is not there's not rootstocks
don't live all by themselves they're not
isolated from from the rest of the ocean
in fact they are an integrated part of
the orchard system to make an orchard
system productive and so all those
interactions if you can imagine you
somewhat have to breed for or account
for when you evaluate and stuff you
can't you can't just focus on you know
soil pH or or disease when a roo stuff
goes out you kind of have to have the
whole spectrum of of those interactions
covered or as many as possible and as
you'll see later sometimes the work that
we do is plant breeders is where we
can't come up with perfection sometimes
we can maybe but we can approximate but
there will always be those those
interactions if you can imagine those
interactions happening in micro climates
around the world which is what we
currently are testing in the Geneva
breeding program we have experiments
from South Africa to to South Korea to
New Zealand Japan and all kinds of other
places so so if you can imagine all
those interactions they are obviously
it's difficult to account for all those
different microclimates so um in the
past few years we learned about some
very unique fruit technologies that that
the geneva rootstocks have imparted to
to science like increase in productivity
that's worth a lot of money the branch
angle modification basically our root
stocks are able to flatten the branches
of trees that are grafted on top and
then reap and diseased dollars this is
the communication in and survival in the
other root systems will happily
resistance and they all they're all
worth a certain amount of money for
apple growers some apple growers you
know want me to to work on mice and
voles and bull resistance you know two
hundred fifty thousand dollars and and a
lab to raise balls but but we can put
that list we can go down that list quite
a bit or I add to that list so a little
bit of history fifty eight fifty years
okay five minutes let's do 50 years in
about two minutes this is when things
sort of started right here in 1968 more
right more like 1969 was the five is
identified as a good parent I have some
some pictures later on and it took this
long in order for the first released to
come out view sixty five and then the
second movies was juice clarity and
three thirty still being planted today
it has you know some some difficulties
and in 1985 dr. Cummings retires
the material was viewed by apple growers
as very valuable but the PIR researcher
was not replaced by and so the growers
went to Congress they said okay so we
need need that material to be
so be preserved and to be advanced into
a finished stage and so the USDA
sort of stepped in through an act of
Congress and they set aside you know
back in the days when they had earmarks
they set aside a certain amount of money
and they hired Bill Johnson who was my
direct predecessor and he was there for
about 18 months and then and then left
and went to breed I think eggplants or
something like that and then that's when
sort of I stepped in and we took the
lead of the breeding program that
happened in 1998 and back in 1998
maybe the production of Geneva
Rousseff's was less than maybe 50,000
pieces a year and we've released we
continue to release several other
rootstocks
dr. all-win can retire right here and
right now we're just about ten million
trees being planted every year if not
more so ten million is is conservative I
think and the demand is still much
higher than the production I remember
walking into
welcome to meeting with Washington
growers when I first started and they
said risk where is the plant material
what happened to it you know we we want
it we want to test see why we want to
plant it and we didn't have enough
production capacity and that was perhaps
one of the hurdles that we have overcome
through research and and also good
technology transfer have a couple of
slides later about that okay so I'm
gonna go through really quickly with
sort of the fact sheets on many of the
ROO stocks that that we released just so
that you know a little bit about them
and about the qualities that they have I
think that we have about 3 million loose
stocks that are planted every year
Levin is resistant to fire blight okay
so all these Bruce talks were bred to to
be resistant to fire blight
i'il deficiency which means that the
rootstock helps the apple tree produce
many more apples for three size so you
can fit you can essentially say you can
produce more apples per acre but
obviously it's not perfect it's
acceptable your belief is then we had G
- OH - and this is our workhorse it's
been around since the 2000s so it's a
really good ruse talk about half of the
marker sharing in New Zealand is his
plant or trees half of the trees are
planted on this first oak in New Zealand
and in the u.s. we have a probably
production of about a million or so t -
two years
I told you that I scanned some pictures
from all times so this is Charlie
standing next to next to a tree and
you'll see in a few you know we're still
doing something similar but hopefully
you know with drones were able to do
something a little bit quicker and and
better but this is G - OH - back in the
90s and this is G 935 this is an
experiment in Italy that that we have
with do 935 it's really gorgeous very
productive tree and we have about 2
million million 1/2 to 2 million trees
being planted every year on this
rootstock it really has some potential
but lately we found some problems with
some viruses and so we're we're
concerned about we're concerned about
that we're finding out what it is that
that is that obviously wasn't tested
before we release it and bred for it but
I said it's a it's also very good
due to can you release it for the Apple
in processing industry because some some
folks wanted a little bit stronger apple
tree a bit bit more vigorous and so I
think you know you all know who you're
more witness right I think he's got an
orchard with jutsu 10 and there's a lot
of a lot of cider varieties and it's
showing out to be a good solution for
that 890 this is the most vigorous of
our releases and if if you recall you
know yield efficiency this this restock
even though it makes a big tree it
produces with a yield efficiency that's
similar to a nine which is a very
dwarfing rootstocks oh so it's it's very
productive
it's and we've tested it in with many
different varieties and many different
things that's just an amazing amazing
roof stock g2 14 is another one which
also is being propagated we're having
some issues with the micropropagation
anybody that has some ideas on how the
root g2 14 can probably make a lot of
money because that's that's the that is
the I guess the the block right now for
high implementation of this roof stock
and a 14 another roof stock that is that
was released based on the on a few
things so it's it's a good propagator
you see this is a propagation bed or
with a 14 and it has a very nice root
system but one of those things that was
very nice about it is this feature right
here
it promotes larger fruit size given
comparable crop load and that's you know
for for an apple grower a slightly
larger apple at least in the u.s. means
money and so if you're able to have a
rooftop that consistently produces
larger slightly larger apples you can
make you know you can you can take that
to the bank quite a bit and we've shown
there's actually good economic data
about that 1969 this is another one of
our recent stars that is taking off as a
rootstock it's here you see it in Italy
and and that is again Charlie
with 969 in the background and that's
the code ala betta my collaborator in
Italy who planted these trees and what's
unique about these theses they have
three buds that have grown independently
into a into a structure three into a
flat structure with with multiple
branches and this is becoming something
that's sort of desirable in in some
places in Europe okay moving on and this
is our latest release I'm going to move
on to I'm going to pass it on but one of
the special things about this roost doc
it's dwarfing and everything with one of
the special things that we found out
through some experiments is that the
root stock actually promotes higher
flowering in the top third of the the
apple tree when children requirement is
not being met so it reduces the Chile
requirement of the same variety we've
done a lot of work looking at this roo
stock here in the US and and and we
found out that it you know the same that
true it was in Brazil it's also the same
and here
we're trying to find out these qtls and
the genes behind the this reduction
transmissible to the Scion for that
there are a lot of online resources for
Geneva rootstocks if you if you want to
go online and look it up you're more
than welcome to to look these two the
more information up okay
so why do they take fifty years to get
here and so this is this is sort of the
my reading chart or the things that we
do to in order to come up with with a
rootstock and in in a few minutes I'll
take you through the life of an apple
rootstock from conception to to
commercialization you can see right here
you have years 27 to 30 it's a little
bit shortened if you use molecular
markers which we do use in a reading
program but it just takes a long time
for a tree to grow into full maturity
and that's the that's the name of it and
then any time you test it into a
different different locality you're
going to encounter different things
cold dry you know whatever and so you
don't know how it performs in a certain
place until you actually test it so I'm
going to take you in a journey through
the development of one of our star Apple
rootstocks
we probably sell about four million
pieces every year and should be probably
seven to eight million of these and in
the future and and then I'll try to
focus a little bit on what's you in
Apple rootstock research so g41 it's a
star really productive rootstock is
resistant to all kinds of pests and
things but
it really and I think the cross started
I'll show you the before we got to this
point where we know about 341 so well
and about what they can do in many
different sit the one of the latest
varieties know if you've heard about
cosmic crisp but the very successful
fire blight in Washington state probably
seeing a supermarket next year this
coming year but these were this this
were probably about three hundred
thousand apple trees grass of constant
crisp grafted on g41 and the but take
was was very very nice so breeding
program before we started really Pro you
have to have sort of an idea of what you
want to do and back in the day when I
was trying to choose when I would go to
wisconsin-madison or North Carolina
State and or our universities I I didn't
know who Randy Gardner was but now I do
very well because Randy Gardner was the
student that did the initial work that
recognized some of the resistant
materials well you have to start from
germ plasm and testing germ plasm before
we make your process and you have to
learn about your germ plasm so here you
have the first stable one at one of the
tables in his thesis and talking about
the seeking inoculations and here's
powers extra basta robust afire
emissions it directly so you know think
about think about that that's the
starting point where you have your
objectives and you think about what the
future is going to be parents were
crossed
here we are using bees to do that
harvest the seeds you know that's okay
fine so that took time and it takes a
lot of effort if we every year to do
that but then the unique things that
that that happen was this disease
screening methods that they they that
herb and Jim Cummings
Gustafson put together and this is what
you know the intention was to kill as
many Roo stocks as possible platanus as
possible very successful and that we're
trying to restart that but these are all
pictures that I took that actually
pictures that I scanned a couple days
ago and much the same of what we are
doing now or if we did back then so we
don't mess what was successful and
that's Gus then we also do a seeding
inoculation for fire blight we don't
need microbe markers now for this
because yeah if it if it shows anything
just throw the way we don't need
anything that is not resistant this is
again a picture probably taken in the
1970s of the inoculation that they were
doing and and and then we have to take
that plant that survives all of that and
we plant it well right now we don't
plant them directly right now they go
through a series of tests with molecular
markers for our marker assisted reading
selection protocol and I'm not going to
have too many or actually I have only
one picture so molecular markers I did
that because I could go on forever and I
don't have forever if I start talking
about you know gene expression and all
that other good stuff it happens but the
important thing is that the plant makes
it out into the field you start to
propagate it we get a initial product
and this is the product that skin sold
to the nurseries that make apple trees
and so we get a first look of that
product we evaluate the rooting then we
take that and we make trees because
that's what we evaluate and so these are
older pictures and then and then we have
Alexis right there that was doing that a
couple of days ago
choose bench crafting trees so that they
can be planted evaluated and we plant
all sorts of orchards and orchards
evaluated for eight to twelve years we
kind of know where the root stock is
gonna do a year seven and and then when
we find out what's working with in that
orchard we grow into a stage where we
take that material we want to know more
about it so we how do you find out more
about a genotype well replicated
experiments but how you run every eight
experiments with four or five these
plants you can't and you can't do you
know you have to just like you do in
corn you have to bulk up the material
either by cell finger hybrids or
whatever and so that's that's largely
the role that Abby has and she has many
different ways and which does that and
that's great because now we've shared
that material with many other different
collaborators in all over the world and
all over the US to find out what these
two stocks do so we continue that and
continue evaluating the material we run
some of the so g-41 had to be run again
to test for fire blight resistant but
now instead of using a mixture reduce as
perhaps separate strains of fire blight
to hit them will have belief its test
again and then again new orchard trials
but these now become the elite orchard
files where we have the material that
that performed well in the first in the
first set and so what we're seeing now
is basically hopefully good stuff well
thanks to molecular markers we now can
go a lot faster here and we can select
things
but this is the way we kind of used to
take notes and everything and then then
you had to transcribe and you know and
we had errors and so forth well few
years ago some some folks in the Midwest
started working on this app and it's
like this more the most wonderful how
many of you have heard about the field
book one two three okay okay so if you
run any experiments any replicating
experiment get the app okay because you
can you know you can enter your your
your experimental design and then
collecting data images you know here I'm
measuring suckering all that stuff is
just like you know very very very easy
so I would recommend to do that and
that's something that you know we used
to do by hand and certain times
assurance time to to come to conclusions
to evaluations okay
ten more minutes so I have to go very
quick so this is also something else
that we used to do to the advanced
tortures we used to spray them with fire
blight in order to find out whether
they're true resistant here's g-41 in
one of those orchards planted many years
ago and and here's Charlie again next to
it and you can see it's a door
productive flat branching nice tree
which was very impressive so we used to
do that we still do it sometimes with
the background but then you know we're
we are trying to graduate into the into
the you know this millennium by using
drones and so Martin hooker is our drone
specialist he's actually licensed to do
that so there's drone is taking pictures
of all the trees and and we were able to
look at those structures and things and
measurements
afterwards so the so that we don't have
to be okay so that we don't have to get
blowing in the wind like it happened
right here all right okay
so we go through the commercial prep
regression trials afterwards where we
share the material with nurseries and so
I know all of our nurseries in the US
and internationally face to face I
visited them I know they're growing
conditions parents also has done that or
dr. Robinson and and that's important
because that relationship allows us to
understand how things are working in at
their locations and it makes us realize
how important they are for the Apple
industry they're the conduit
by which our product Bruce toss gets
transferred to operators and so we have
to we can't just release material and
just put the blinders on say it's gonna
do something and we were actually
actively engaged with several of our
nurseries we had a we had a great
technology transfer specialist here at
Cornell Jessica lega that helped us out
and I'll have a few but what we do at
that stage is when we have bulk topped
the material we collaborate with a group
of scientists that's been meeting for
about past 35 years evaluating new
stocks in a replicated matter so these
are experiments that have the same
genotypes the same number of
replications and they're planted all
over the US and they've received you
know the group has received
commendations and Wars because of the
type of work that they did and the
impact that it's had literally millions
of dollars if not hundreds of minutes or
hours and the other point of that was I
wanted to make is that by doing this
this replicated trials we create
a lot more knowledge because when you
add now the information that you have
for one rootstock on to all these these
different trials you find out that you
know by the time that you release it you
have about 300 to 400 power ears at
different locations and that's and
that's valuable ah a little bit of
something so we've been in the breeding
program we've had to do make choices so
we do we did we choose grower industry
or fancy science and hopefully we've
always chosen for the benefit of growers
I find sometimes that a scientist know
we can get sucked into a scholar rabbit
hole is that correct
you know of RNA seek or you know this
gene or whatever and and whereas my our
main main role is to produce appaluse
stocks for apple growers not that fancy
I mean the reviewers don't like you know
don't like to know that if M Nye is less
productive than g41 or whatever who
cares are most reviewers in in the fancy
science but growers do and so sometimes
the the interest of reviewers journals
granting agencies as well and all kinds
of things are not very well aligned with
with the interest of apple growers and
so I have a fault that I had a big
folder of unpublished science that you
know retired and then spent the next ten
years I could probably cover everything
but afterwards g---forty wanted to be
tested on farms so so we also have these
relationships relationship with with
farmers and here's Bob black Maryland if
you go on fifteen Catoctin Mountain
orchards and fields file I love this guy
but I also love all the other couple
growers that I did I interact with they
they get to experience to roost up
materials and get to give me feedback
oh that three is too big over here or
then produce many ethyl sorry but my
annual you know you got was here
something and and so and then we get to
see it also in different locations of
filled with Apple ooh stocks in
Washington State
reason is so doc is because that was
doing the fires that they were they were
occurring two years ago but that's 341
and and it's being bought it or grafted
we also these field trials for growers
help us realize how good these root
stocks are and you can send that message
to the apple growers so this was what
the orchard looked like initially this
is in Utah in Spanish work and it's a
fire blight area like one of the best
areas to test fire blight and this is
the orchard afterwards I think it took
only two years for for all the m26 trees
we had planted our trees interspersed
into into the rows and so our three
survived now and and so they had to take
out that orchard they did fortunately
they took all of our trees and
transplanted into a different location
so you still have a field trial but now
it's only Geneva rue stocks now last
year and and I want to continue mention
in this last year they had a major fire
by epidemic in Washington State I don't
think we lost one Geneva three but they
folks probably they're lost about a
hundred million worth of of trees so I'm
gonna go quick more trials and more
field trials and and so and this is the
perhaps the something that I need to
mention we use molecular markers in the
breeding program and they're worth some
money into in terms of selection they
save money because we don't have to
plant so many
in the field or valuate so perhaps the
most impactful use of molecular markers
that we that we did knowing what the
genotype was was to find out what was
going out in the industry and the
mixtures and things that happen makes
you sure that things work correctly so
we caught situations where a hundred
thousand plants had to be thrown out
okay so a hundred thousand that's you
know if you do $5 apiece or or whatever
you do the numbers okay and that was
maybe a $50 $100 reaction to do so
sometimes you know we focus on science
but things actually have molecular
markers actually have a very nice thing
stage 10 micropropagation and then we
release it and so I was talking about
many different nurseries and and and we
do work with a lot of these nurseries
but research continues after release and
it's amazing how much more knowledge we
had to build up about g-41 and other
rootstocks after it was released after
was made public after I wrote the patent
now the cross was made in I think in
1975 or 1976
so and it was patented in 2006 but these
are replant experiments that happen and
were the results were out in 2008 2012
and so on so forth that show all the
good things that g41 has beyond what was
initially selected for and so here's
fully Appalachia the experiments that
where we found out that orchards that
plant this root stock don't have to
spray anymore for we have belief it's
because because of well because the the
will happen if it dies in the root
system and so this is an experiment in
Italy where two different brew stocks
were planted and one was covered with
will happily fit actually this one and
the other one was completely clean
so and then
you know obviously propagation
experiments that's a place and more
propagation but then we have those
situations where I talked about and I
have two more minutes I know you give me
a time but where things sometimes don't
go well with a particular rootstock and
in a particular sign combination and
these were actually about 50,000 trees
worth about 10 bucks apiece maybe less I
don't know but they were gorgeous trees
and they were huge and in the and
because they were so huge and nice in
the nursery they all got blown in the
wind and they broke off right here
because g-41 happens to have a some sort
of a graph Union strength problem call
it a quirk it doesn't have it with with
with with all the same varieties and so
we had to do research after long after
it was released
if you study what what works and you
know we broke all kinds of trees and
with students and and and looked at the
application of fight of hormones and did
molecular work on this and all of that
and you know looked at hormone through
xylem extraction found out that hormones
were actually different in in in the
different root stocks and just expensive
works but still you know after the blue
stock was released and this is free this
is Jame Lord done he was a postdoc in in
Terrance Robb business lab and he's the
one that did the work on on hormones but
how valuable is to understand that even
though it's you know after after release
another thing that we did oh I have to
go pick on this was to find out what you
know rootstocks kind of get nutrients
from the soil
that's why that's one of the things that
they do and what we found out is that
they have some different qualities with
regards to the ability to update
nutrients and transfer transmit them to
the science and so if you see right here
blue is low red side this is actually
boron we measure boron in leaves and
fruit and peel and so on and so forth
and what we found out is that for some
nutrients and this is over four years
okay for some nutrients some Rousseff's
are very very well dialed in
genotypically
to absorb only so much of that nutrient
but what happens if you make fertilizer
recommendations based on on these
nutrient on these on these root stocks
you end up you know over prescribing too
much medicine especially when you plant
these you said the root stocks which are
a lot more efficient at that so we're
dealing with finding out all of these
new things about about the these root
stocks many many years after after that
that you know obviously the nutrients
affect calcium and bitter bit and so
here perhaps this is going to be money
this is this is a new method so 50 years
ago 40 years ago 20 years ago even a
year ago we used to send in material to
a lab to measure potassium and calcium
well we have this little instrument
right here that allows us to to measure
potassium and calcium is cerebellar or
thickened and this is an R of 87 and in
the R square is for benefit prediction
so it predicts bitter pit and it's
amazing at doing that and it's an
amazing piece of an amazing instrument
so you think I'm gonna go through here
and and this is some of the research
that we're doing with airport
looking looking at a true systems this
is a couple weeks ago and now we have I
think it was about 100,000 plants right
there of g-41 and here that we're
getting more different it was getting
buggered so all the meetings other
people talking about it with trees in
the background and and a lot of
scientists engaged so it doesn't take
these are folks from Kazakhstan that are
interested in planting some of our and
testing some of the root stocks but good
that transfer doesn't happen in a vacuum
it you need to do it you need to work on
and so we were fortunate to win an award
against labs like the Sandia Labs NASA
the Naval Research Laboratory for
technology transfer because of the work
that we did with with our customers
apple growers Apple nurseries and and so
a lot of that work happened with with
Cornell here's Jessica lega and visiting
our nurseries we want to be fair to
growers and give good opportunities to
or to our to our to our growers and so
we did a lot of work of that crowning
jewel I guess for g-41 Apple roof stock
it was named as the from outstanding
fruit varieties from from the AHS so all
those things take a lot of effort and a
lot of people and I'm really grateful
really really grateful for all those
that participated in the 50 years I'm
sure that I missed some people didn't
recognize and I'm sorry about that but
it kind of gives you an idea of all of
the work that goes into developing a new
system or an order or a rootstock it's a
lot it's a lot more work than cucumbers
I'll I'll test you that so with that I'd
like to thank you and
[Applause]
one or two questions how to the
introductions from your program whether
it's g-41 or others actually made it to
the growers a couple of ways so they
usually if they're if it's a test
agreement if you have testing it we
develop the the plant material and we
actually give it to them to test under
and the material test agreement but if
they're they make it through the nursery
so nurseries are an essential component
of propagating your material and our
nurseries are licensed to propagate
forty-one and things like that but for
the testing we kind of go directly with
to them and we pick and choose the best
so yep so the question is this fire
blight resistance moved to the science
so and the answer is yes maybe so we had
some experiments that showed in fact
this was the first paper published on on
graph transmissibility of anything by mu
stocks which showed that the tsiyon is
modified transcriptionally so there's a
there's different changes that happen
because of the ROO stock so perhaps that
that's that's occurring we have some
hearsay and and had some proof that the
sign material had less incidence of fire
blight on the top I think the biggest
say the biggest
saving element compared to a service a
secular brew stock is the fact that the
root stock is still alive when it when
it reached me when you have a fire
blight strike but if it's a susceptible
new stop the root stock dies what
happens when the root system dies you
lose the tree and that's and so so so
there are benefits in keeping the tree
healthy or live where the strike that
happens on top you can you're able to
prune it and overcome that but there are
also perhaps benefits there are graft
transmissible and that research has
happened but I think a lot more could be
could be done especially with a larger
number of rooftops
thank you for having me this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu